hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades the wait is almost over here
are all eight free games for PlayStation
Plus subscribers during the month of
November 2017 this month we have four
games for the ps4 one of which is an
awesome VR title two more for the ps3
and two for the Vita as well this month
we have scares battles platforming a
point-and-click adventure and the smash
bros esque fighting fest oh and there's
also a little extra for PS Plus
subscribers coming in December I'll tell
you about that once we've checked out
all eight games as always let's start
with the headlining ps4 titles and
kicking off the month is battlegrounds
sadly it's not player unknowns
battlegrounds it's worms battlegrounds
there's no denying the worms franchise
is iconic and if you've never played one
with friends then this is worth your
time first released in 2014 this is a
turn-based artillery centered strategy
game that may sound more complex than
actually is kill everyone who isn't in
your squad weapons include donkeys sheep
launchers and the more routine methods
of death such as grenades and guns the
single-player will help you hone your
skills but this must be played with
others to truly get the party buy the
game is renowned for its reviews ant
great ranging from about 60% up to the
mid 70s but if you need a way to sort
out an argument without punching someone
in the face try worms battlegrounds next
on the ps4 is bound a simply beautiful
3d platformer with an awesome soundtrack
it's probably more recognizable as an
artistic outing rather than a
traditional video game as you control an
unnamed princess who can't resist
busting out her ballet moves bound is
set in the mind of a woman who is
reliving her childhood memories you have
a simple task vanquish a monster the
visual sometimes use real-life rather
than the art style you're seeing now
it's hard to sell this title you really
must play it for yourself to understand
and if you are a psvr
owner it fully supports your headset at
present it holds a Metacritic score of
70% let's take things up a notch with
this month's psvr title until dawn rush
off blood this is absolute
the excellent and bloody scary at times
it's an on-rails shooter with a few jump
scares to keep your foot cheek tense
although it has the untilled our name it
is very far from that experience
although a few characters and locations
do pop up from time to time if you are
not ready to say bye to Halloween throw
on a headset and shoot clowns I think we
can all agree that clowns are scary as
hell guess what that's you is still here
on PS Plus it's been here for so long
that I'm not going to talk about it
anymore let's move on over to the ps3 if
you miss the days of super smash bros
and are still gaming on your ps3 then
pick up ragdoll kungfu fists of plastic
go toe to toe with eight different
action figures customize them to your
own unique and weird ways and then beat
ten bells of [ __ ] out of each other
simple as that
the control system uses different
buttons to control different limbs and
feels a lot like gang beasts grabbing it
I'd love to know your thoughts
next on the ps3 is yet another classic
franchise our type this time is
dimensions hopping back to the 1990s and
the influx of side-scrolling
shoot-'em-up s-- this one completely
lives up to its arcade roofs its
massively repetitive but that's what you
get with this type of genre it's all
about trial error and replay over to the
beta and dungeon punks which is also
available on your ps4 a fast paced
role-playing game with a really cool
tag-team fighting system if you've ever
played Golden Axe it's like that but
with RPG elements for additional depth
ultimately it's a side-scrolling brawler
but it's more than that if you want it
to be does anyone actually still play
their Vita or am I the last one
remaining and finally yet another
classic game Broken Sword 5 episodes 1 &
2 are available on your Vita this is a
point-and-click behemoth which has seen
better days if I'm honest playing as
George and Nico you must complete
puzzles to progress the narrative this
was so loved 20 plus years ago the main
funding behind this project came from
the fans raising over $800,000 are you
one of them if you are I salute you to
change the direction for a moment during
Paris games week we've had an update on
monster hunter world and the beta which
starts on December the 9th why am i
bringing this up
well this will only be available to PS
Plus subscribers so mark it in your
calendar as it will only be here for
four days but don't worry I will remind
you next month so there we have it eight
PS plus games for the month of November
2017 what do you think to the lineup
I'll be honest I was expecting better
ps4 options but with the PS BR titled
rush of blood I'm a pretty happy bunny
what are you grabbing and are you
satisfied with the haul of this month
let me know your thoughts I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]